hier soir la lumière est bonne ici la
lumière est bonne la le sujet pour bien
la lumière et bien bonjour les amis de
retour du japon je suis avec sensei
carlitos sensei max jeu m'a coupé les
mecs je la fais une petite surprise j'ai
besoin touché au genou j'ai ramené des
objets d'un magasin qui s'appelle le
dôme qui tu t'inquiètes c'est quoi ces
magasins t'imagines carrefour sur cinq
étages et le dernier étage c'est que des
bêtises de la valise et là bas vu que
j'affirme darné soit faire de convenir à
chacun de tous rechercher un objet ok
pourquoi aussi loin je ne sais pas mais
j'ai vraiment hâte de mettre l évolution
pourrait la mettre la wii et les deux
personnes qui n'ont pas cherché objets
devront occuper les gens ok bon c'est
comme ça c'est grâce à toi c'est toi qui
jouit il est mignon petit shibata acheté
au japon d'un paillage avec maxence et
bah vous ressemblez oil & gas première
objet c'est 1,2 me flingue espère
sûrement cet objet est extrêmement cool
c'est une roulette russe avec des bals
des fois ça va taper le ballon qu'en
salle tape le ballon va péter je peux
affirmer que le loup du fond de la
classe de la vidéo n'en dit pas des fois
on est parfois pour ceux qui au vu du
voyage au bout de l'enfer avec jack
layton à la wii ce beau monde de hockey
était prêt tu commences tu parles de ton
oreille et appuyer sur la détente
[Musique]
j'ai peur de rien on a survécu plus vrai
plus breton que ma collection de one
piece il ne faut pas la toucher est 1re
obligé j'aurais peut-être un pronostic
c'est un des meilleurs jeux crime allez
vas-y tu as fait quoi
non mais cette mexes as et je me suis
dit oh c'est pourtant chiba oui c'est
pour mon chien c'est un jouet il avait
le même là où il est tulle aime
tellement ton chien tu avais fait
c'était pas terrible on n'a pas de bar
parminou personnes donc cet objet est
clair d'intérêt à la pensée non on peut
le porter le reste de la vidéo
ok ok même avec ces simples ça va être
un match de quelque chose de pas
ridicule s'instaure certifié par le
japon c'est faux
[Musique]
alors on compterait nombre de balles à
la fin car dans le monde doit se les met
nous-mêmes d'enflammer un mois moi je
l'aimé jamais dans toi et ensuite c'est
bon j'aime quand tu me mets au mellah
petites blagues de cul la kippa non
heureusement c'est du made in japan
c'est très solide
ok ce qu'on doit faire je monte en poids
de l'eau bienvenue dans cette partie de
ping pong tête qui ne manquent pas comme
si j'en jouais à nous car litho qui
viennent du brésil un bouquin au char à
boeufs alors nouvel objet de la miss
1 tu attaques on commente une sorte
c'est un bel objet nouvel objet alors
j'ai pris des risques en menant sa
puisqu'il contient de la poudre pour
faire finalement exploser des billets de
dix mille yens le principe est très
simple quand j'ai tiré sur cette corde y
aura un maximum de billets qui vont
tomber
de fait on aimerait des vrais billets
non et oui [ __ ] ya des béquilles mais
demandez le programme et les pédagogues
qui tire sur la ficelle
moi j'adore tes passionnés sur scène
voilà tout ça tu te la donne ça sent bon
alors moi j'adore ça moi l'audition voix
calme toi mes mecs je pensais que les
billets il était par contre on passe à
la suite
alors ce bureau va brûler alors là
tendent à nous mêmes c'est vraiment le
bordel si l'objet est une fausse rose je
pleure de l'est alors c'est une rose que
tu offres à ta copine est en fait dans
la recette chaque objet est cassé ou
cassables s'est fait dans la rue ses
cages et mme pilotte a c'est tout
c'est plus des objets cultes
spécificités non mais ne vous ai pas
compris le principe c'est que tu as fait
une rosière fait deux ans cache une
culotte pas ces genres un truc
romantique avec deux sacs thedan oui bah
ouais bon niveau supérieur tourner dans
le pétard et je parle pas que ça faisait
quelque chose
mm 72e chose le truc avant sauf que
c'est censé faire un maximum de bruit
vous l'avons annoncé peut-être bonjour
raison donc bon un peu de retenue un peu
de calme s'asseoir et on travaille s'il
vous plaît tu tu meurs slip et eu mon
fils sera avec plaisir
pendant ce temps là on va combler un mec
t'es mort
écoute soit sa mauvaise passe et ensuite
j'ai fait ça pour me faire brute à 7 une
histoire douce avec un petit lapin qui
[Applaudissements]
n'ont ils auraient dû péter en fait il a
même été si si regardez avoir garé à
l'oeil à le tuer maintenant le titan
colossal franchement ça fait plaisir ça
mais au ton direct à des musulmans
surtout ça fait s'affoler à bout après
une bonne base pour fêter noël puisque
dix jours sans vous au japon les gages
de long senti tellement mal moi aussi
grave pendant ce n'était pas là j'ai
vraiment bad est assez simple c'est un
objet un ustensile vraiment apprécié
pour faire la fête
qu'est ce que c'est bien donc lâché au
compteur pour fêter ça et lucas tu viens
de gagner 600 millions d'euros au loto
plus car tu as reçu un message e sexy de
harry roselmack jusqu'à ton père vient
de mourir alors là mais qu est-ce que
vous l'appréciez ce jackie chan je lui
ai acheté un copain voulez-vous
découvrir la tête de l'acteur en
question s'il vous plaît on peut on peut
chercher pouvez chercher les indices il
est il est il pas énormément alors
américain de nom il est nomade de peau
ou blanc de peut-être c'est un acteur
américain qui est pèse énormément et
manon kg il passe beaucoup en masse
musculaire aussi le rock win win jones
attention voici le corps ils ont un truc
au japon avec les gros seins non mr j'ai
pris un
j'ai pris un pantalon trop petite je
dois pas le pousser plus loin se passe
très très studieux je tienne de
figurines chat a l'habitude de descendre
et elle m'a fait est souvent avec ma
fille dit yes le corps est pris aux
tombes bolide
donnez moi je cherche à élever son
fiancé est pas restée là bas moi
j'adorerais une femme avec un corps
comme ça mais le visage de mes parents
parce qu'ils n'établissent assez vous
l'avez fait une fracture non mais pour
s'offrir un nouvel élément de déco alors
direct à l'eau
les mecs se contentent suis là j'avais
hâte de tester ce sont des pilules pour
sentir mauvais de la laine
ok ricard d'étoilés c'est moi je veux
pas essayer j'ai trop une angoisse a
créé les haleines quitte là alors je ne
sais pas comment ça marche
mais je suppose qu'il faut mélanger
social de les effets mommens later mais
que non mais regardez legs
c'est horrible avec cette météo mais ça
ça valent pas mais si bien que je le
vois pas mais que vous m'aimez c'est
incroyable israël tu vois ça tout de
suite
mais mes gars y'a rien à la clé qui
parmi vous envie de boire sa météo
commentaires tag est quelqu'un qui n'a
pas besoin de ça que j'ai acheté un
objet qui te permet de boire sans avoir
à les chercher ton verre il s'agit d'une
taille de 3 mètres mcfly prend la cam tu
va cadrer et toi tu vas tu vas suivre le
liquide à travers la loi tu veux mais
quand moi
c'est en mai chez les femmes
[Musique]
pour le bois les gars allez on finit
anges
oui on va arranger vous êtes inquiète
les amis et bilan des courses
est ce que raphaël plus de la gueule
mais je crois que c'était déjà avant
olol au bon c'est inattendu ça alors ça
c'est un objet je n'ai pas compris
regardez surtout c'est françois hollande
mais le mec oui ouais c'est vrai ce que
tu peut allumer ses data loader
d'honneur moi c'est quand même vrai et
d'ailleurs peut-être pardon
les amis dernier objet vous allez finir
avec la tête de ce japonais ici présents
qui veut tester moi ok nikkei ou alors
c'est la meilleure invention de tous les
temps ça tu me le dire je ne suis pas
ton chercheur je suis pas ta petit peu
plus ok je suis pas une victime on va en
discuter ce sont des claquettes sur ses
claquettes je vais disposer de manière
adéquate
une simulation de lego juste ici de
manière à ce que sur la claquette il y
ait une sorte de lego qui ressort mcfly
je vais l'inviter c'est horrible l'ex
andry cette vidéo sur ses pieds il gère
mieux
merci d'avoir regardé à bientôt monde
grâce aux jeunes
[Musique]